quiero empezar haciendo un experimento
así que les voy a pedir a todos en sus
bolsas
les han dejado algunos papeles sino una
libretica
y tienen un bolígrafo
agregamos la siguiente actividad
creo que en ese papel
escriban la respuesta a esta pregunta
que me hace feliz que nos hace felices a
ustedes
qué es lo que le da sentido a sus vidas
vamos a tomarnos unos segundos para que
escriban en el papel
a veces puede ser una pregunta un poco
complicada
pero seguro que si miran dentro de su
corazón van a saber que los hace feliz
así que les voy a dar unos segundos
una vez que escriban
les va a pedir un favor
él va a pedir que lo doble
las veces que ustedes consideren
necesario doble en el papel
y pasen se lo
a alguien a la persona de al lado del
frente de atrás lo importante es que
nadie quede con su propio papel
les voy a pedir el favor de que hagan
exactamente lo siguiente lo mismo que yo
voy a hacer
listos
en estos papeles
y algunos que ustedes tenían
estaba lo que hacía más felices algunas
de las personas que están acá
eso es lo que pasa cuando una enfermedad
discapacitante grave o mortal llega a
nuestras vidas nos quita lo que nos hace
más felices
lo que le da sentido a nuestras vidas
hace
unos años
yo tuve que tomar la decisión más
difícil de mi vida
estaba en budapest
por esa época yo trabajaba en finlandia
y estaba allí para una reunión de
trabajo
era un domingo más o menos a las 10 de
la noche y yo estaba el teléfono
al otro lado de la línea estaba mi mamá
mi tío y el médico que en ese momento
atendía a mi padre internado en el
hospital
esa noche
yo decidí quitarle todo el soporte que
mantenía vivo a mi padre
y sabía que iba a morir a los días
o de pronto en contadas horas
al día siguiente viaje alguien se llega
a bogotá
y vi a mi padre dos horas vivo antes que
muriera
tomar la decisión de que alguien muera
es muy duro
pero es mucho más duro cuando este papá
y es que yo creo que
lo más importante de la vida
es la vida misma
no hay nada que supere el estar vivo
esa noche
a pesar de lo difícil de la decisión
hubo una cosa que me facilitó tomarla
y es que por la enfermedad de mi padre
ya ni el mi mamá eran felices
no había momentos de felicidad
y como decía un famoso comediante
americano george carlin
la vida no se mide por las veces que uno
respira sino por los momentos que nos
quitan el aliento
la enfermedad y padre fue larga
y fue lo más cercano que he tenido a un
problema de salud grave
durante esos años eso me permitió
reflexionar sobre varias cosas uno la
importancia de tener un diagnóstico
adecuado y oportuno la importancia de
tener un tratamiento seguro y eficaz
la importancia de tener acceso al avance
tecnológico a la innovación para tratar
la enfermedad
y es que a lo largo de los años
la salud de mis capacidades de llorando
muchas veces por fallas en alguno de
estos puntos
pero no solamente
empeoraba su calidad de vida sino que
adicionalmente cada vez tratarla costaba
más
y yo creo que ahí está uno de los
grandes problemas
que tiene nuestros sistemas de salud
y es que muchas veces por ahorrar
no hacemos las intervenciones adecuadas
en el momento oportuno y eso acarrea una
vez mejora en la salud de los pacientes
y un costo más alto para el sistema
y el gran problema creo yo
es que vemos la salud como un gasto y no
como una inversión
y hay una gran diferencia cuando entre
un gasto y una inversión porque un gasto
es simplemente el egreso de dinero a
cambio de un bien o servicio pero una
inversión es realmente utilizar recursos
buscando un beneficio y en salud muchas
veces ese beneficio es a largo plazo
déjenme tratar de darles otro ejemplo
para ilustrar esto que les quiero decir
imaginemos un paciente con cáncer de
mama
el cáncer de mama es una enfermedad
compleja que necesita estar bien
caracterizada
porque hay varios tipos de cáncer de
mama y si no sabemos cuál es no lo vamos
a poder tratar correctamente
un paciente que llega con un cáncer de
mama temprano en estadios tempranos y es
mal diagnosticado
lo que estamos haciendo es afectando su
expectativa de vida porque ese paciente
al año llega con un cáncer ya avanzado
y la diferencia en términos de su
expectativa de vida es muy grande entre
un cáncer temprano y uno avanzado pero
no solamente eso según la cuenta de alto
costo tratar un cáncer estadios en
estadios tempranos es aproximadamente 17
veces más económico que tratando lo de
que tratarlo cuando el cáncer está en
nuestra vida avanzado y ya es
metastásico invertir en salud
implica hacer varias cosas implica
invertir en concientización de la
población en educación en capacitación
en infraestructura en el acceso al
diagnóstico oportuno adecuado
en el acceso a tratamientos seguros
eficaces el acceso a la innovación
durante mis años en finlandia
experimenté cosas muy buenas entre ellas
cómo funciona un sistema de salud en un
país como estos
y sobre todo en temas de prevención
en dos años que estuvimos allá fuimos
citados a varios exámenes a mi esposa la
citaron a sus exámenes rutinarios in
ecológicos también necesitan un examen
de ojos para que yo de la edad
sopena que no podía manejar o conducir
un auto si no me lo hacía
a mis hijos los citaron a varios
exámenes propios de su edad en dos años
en finlandia nos llegaron nos llamaron
llegaron más citaciones a exámenes
preventivos que todos los que he
recibido en diez años viviendo américa
latina como decía invertir es utilizar
recursos buscando un beneficio
y para mí cuando invertimos en salud hay
dos beneficios clarísimos
el primero la felicidad
pero no porque ustedes hayan hecho este
ejercicio que estoy seguro nos ha hecho
reflexionar un poco sobre la importancia
de la salud de nuestra felicidad sino
porque un grupo de investigadores
que preparan el reporte mundial de
felicidad para la onu
consideran el acceso a la salud como uno
de los elementos uno de los componentes
importantes para este ranking en este
ranking los países que ocupan los
primeros puestos son países como
finlandia noruega dinamarca islandia
suiza colombia ocupa el puesto 37 en
este rango lo que me parece irónico es
que estos países que están de primero
son países donde la temperatura en
invierno a veces alcanza los menos 30
grados centígrados y créanme que así es
yo lo viví
o donde por ejemplo en invierno el sol
cuando sale sale menos de 5 horas al día
esos países son más felices según este
ranking que colombia un país con un
clima tropical
y con el ambiente fiestero que nos
caracteriza
pero el segundo
beneficio de invertir en salud y para mí
el más importante es el impacto que esto
tiene en el crecimiento económico
y comienzo ilustrándolo con una
investigación un estudio
preparo una investigadora latina bogdan
que presentó en el fiba 2016
el estudio se llama el papel de la salud
en el crecimiento económico y ahí ella
concluye
que mejorar la salud de la población
puede beneficiar el crecimiento
económico de las personas y de los
países
y que por consiguiente las naciones
deberían ver el gasto en salud no como
un costo sino como una inversión hay
también un estudio publicado por el buró
nacional de investigaciones económicas
que menciona que incrementar un año y la
expectativa de la población puede tener
un impacto en la productividad del 4%
cuando yo empiezo a reflexionar sobre
todas estas cosas
creo que hay un efecto importante en el
mantener a las personas de la adulta en
buena calidad de vida y mantener a los
abuelos con buena calidad de vida y
quiero ilustrarlo con otro ejercicio ya
se dieron cuenta que me gustan los
ejercicios y los experimentos así que
vamos a hacer una pequeña encuesta les
voy a pedir a todas las personas que
tienen hijos
y que alguna vez han tenido que dejar a
sus hijos al cuidado de sus padres es
decir los abuelos de ellos
o aquellos que no tienen hijos
que recuerdan que alguna vez se quedaron
al cuidado de sus abuelos que levanten
la mano levanten la mano
pero que no me equivoco sí sí es todo el
salón
yo no pude hacerlo 15 años que estuve
por fuera no lo podía hacer
las distancias logísticamente me
impedían pero es un hecho que los
abuelos
están ahí
en el momento que sus hijos más los
necesitan
dónde está ese pico de productividad
y que apoya el crecimiento económico
individual pero además el crecimiento
económico colectivo del país está mi
felicidad
mi familia compartir momentos que quedan
para el recuerdo con mi esposa con mis
dos hijas gemelas con mi hijo con mi
mamá
por lo que les comenté hoy mi padre ya
nos puede acompañar en esta foto
eso es lo que yo escribo escrito mi
papel
en su bolsa hay más papel
escriban lo que los hace feliz pero esta
vez no dejen que nadie se lo rompa que
nadie les quite su felicidad atrás
[Aplausos]